la frc a le département de la réunion le
syndicat du sucre de la réunion nous
présente terre d'ici
pour
producteur de curcuma à la plaine des
grègues guibert hoarau cultive également
une autre plante emblématique de notre
île la route
originaire d'amérique tropicale on
l'appelle aussi marrante la route tire
son nom de la forme particulière de son
rhizome pointu c'est comme une flèche
sur les voies la pâture et l'arrière et
rond elle dépense et patuc voir son nom
la hotoie ici dans les hauts de saint
joseph le terroir est idéal pour cette
culture
même si le nombre de cultivateurs se
comptent sur les doigts de la main une
dizaine à peine guibert lui tout comme
ses parents l'ont fait depuis toujours
continue de cultiver la route de manière
traditionnelle présentés soit les
patates voilà la plante elle-même parce
qu'on récolte est respectée petit bout
avec la plante on peut replanter
j'entends qu'on paie rien mais c'est
planté à partir du mois d'août ou de
septembre octobre et récolté à partir d
un peu révolté au mois de juillet mais
c'est pas rentable
le bon mois c'est au mois d août
septembre octobre au départ il faut
quand même pas beaucoup d'eau après ça
tient bien même ce serait ça résiste
bon c'est tintin ont été emmenés à 10
avec le vin blanc mais sa maintenance à
diminuer si les problèmes auxquels
aucune maladie pour la sérié pas de
souci pas de souci en effet après la
plantation à part peut-être les
mauvaises herbes que gilbert prend soin
d'arracher régulièrement de son champ
quand c'est propre ça développe mieux
c'est cette pensée ans a été plantée au
mois d'octobre
ça va être récoltées au mois d'août pas
vraiment un entretien à sport tas a
relevé de l'eab pas fumier pas d'engrais
pas l'insecticide on peut dire que ce
duo l'a7 dans la valée vraiment et je
cassiers sert de l'eau mais devant ça va
fleurir au mois de mai juin ils furent
blanche donc blanche la fleur blanche la
poudre blanche après la floraison
la récolte des précieux rhizome d'arrout
débute en plein hiver austral
en tenant compte cependant de la lune
juillet on peut commencer mais ses
parents terme au niveau poudres alors le
mois d'août c'est mi août septembre
octobre
et pour la transmission il faut regarder
la lune ces trois joueurs ou 3 3 ou 4
jours avant le plat ou après c'est à lui
qu'il faut plus si on fait la nouvelle
lune y aura beaucoup moins de poudre que
quand on fait un nul
juste avant ou juste après après
l'arrachage les racines sont bien
nettoyée avant de procéder à
l'extraction de l'amidon qui donnera au
final la précieuse poudre blanche non
soit bien blanc ensuite mis au broyeur
et après passé sur les bains sur les
flux avec un tamis et c'est quelque
chose qu'il faut beaucoup de pauvres
pour travailler la première fois il faut
deux heures on laisse reposer deux
heures ensuite la deuxième fois il faut
trois à quatre heures même cinq heures
est là pour la troisième fois on l'a su
nuit lendemain on enlève dans les fûts
au mieux sous l'oeil sur ses tableaux
avec une arme et une toile dessus assez
aimée au séchoir là bas sous le séchoir
faut que tout pas de poussière que ce
soit bien a bien compris on obtient une
poudre blanche de qualité voilà une très
bonne qualité ça sera bien bien blancs
pauvres
après le curcuma la route et l'autre
culture phare de la plaine des grègues
dans ce joli village des hauts de
saint-joseph
gilbert hoarau continue dans la
tradition la culture de cette plante aux
racines blanches si prisé grâce à un
terroir favorable les champs d'arrout
post ici dans des conditions optimales
avec un rendement à l'hectare très
intéressant chien étant on peut quand
même avoir rentré de 3,3 tonnes de brut
et sur wii avec le coeur que moi c'est
la moitié et je suis à deux ans tandis
que les routiers on a l'assurance de la
qualité
ces garanties c'est bien fait mais c'est
bien hermétique bas on emballe au furet
mais j'accorde qui à la demande soit
conditionnée en sachets ou bien en vrac
guibert commercialise sa production
directement sur place et à l'occasion
des foires apprécié pour ses vertus
médicinales
cette poudre immaculé sert aussi à la
confection de délicieux bonbons la route
là en train de mélanger la peau de route
avec le sucre glace
ensuite laurent albert après bien
travailler la pâte
alors on écrase bien voilà grâce bien le
beurre avec capote
ensuite il ya les rois leblanc dire qui
revient avec après une fois pétri
marie-laure étale la pâte et forme à
l'aide d'un verre les fameux bonbons
il faut pas la pâte est trop tendre
voilà et il faut parler trop dure il
faut les il faut essayer de faire plus
ou moins et call badigeonnez d'un jaune
d'oeuf les bonbons sont alors enfourner
mais il faudra encore un peu de patience
avant de pouvoir les déguster
maintenant la cuisson bas deux parties
trente minutes à 200 voilà entre temps
il faut être au bout de 4 minutes
d'échangés inverse sur les plateaux
voilà guilbert et marie-laure façon est
ainsi régulièrement des bonbons la route
maison à partir d'une recette
traditionnelle que leur a donné un ami
avant c'était les vieilles grand mec
faisait maintenant repris mais on a eu
la recette avec un an chinois la camorra
de nous merci ce n'est pas la première
fois qu'on a pu faire avec le temps on a
l'a bien reçue bien vérifier maintenant
c'est nous si les gens achètent une fois
il conviendrait reviennent chercher
c'est pas ma façon qu'on me dit de façon
dont la route
c'est le vrai le vrai de vrai voilà
c'est un vrai petit pays c'est pas
mélanger c'est parfois décès garantie
100% alors vous êtes satisfaite du
résultat est oui
lemieux s'est laissé deux ou trois jours
avant le danger mais fondée dans la
bouche
les familles se conserve et puis on peut
le déguster comme ça tel quel avec un
café café avec athée
tout